bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
édition du 12 13 ans en normandie en
direct du village des jeux équestres
mondiaux nous avons installé notre
studio toute cette semaine nous sommes
au sein de l'événement mondial de
l'équitation quinze jours de compétition
qui se poursuivent ce mercredi avec en
ce moment même au stade dans l'anneau le
grand prix spécial de dressage deux
cavaliers français est attendu dans la
carrière ce matin
l'événement de la fin de semaine sur ces
jeunes ce sera aussi le début du
concours complet dans l'or noir a du
pain cinquante mille personnes sont
attendues les délégations seront déjà
arrivé depuis quelques jours et pour les
accueillir le lieu du véritablement se
métamorphoser le reportage d'appel de
safi et de damian mignot
au perdu classé du haras du pin des
rangées de fond des mers 160 chambres
deux étoiles tous les cavaliers des
fédérations sont logés là avec les
vétérinaires les chefs d'equipe donc
l'hébergement temporaire qui est là et
qui repart france une semaine et des
chambres tout confort avec climatisation
télévision et internet
gauche valette et trois ligues c'est
super c'est très proche avec les jeux
mal et c'est super c'est très pratique
en plus des cavaliers les vétérinaires
les chefs d'equipe il a aussi fallu
trouver une solution pour loger tous
ceux qui s'occupent des chevaux au plus
près des écuries pour les groupes de lit
ce sont des conteneurs pliable
contrairement à ceux pour les cavaliers
en plus de tous les hôtels temporaire il
y a aussi ses camions qui ont servi à
amener les chevaux et dans lesquelles
vivent certains membres des délégations
vivien de cire très bien vu cochettes
séjour cuisine
parfaite tombe bien la stade et on
dansera
mes jeux équestres le haras du pin a dû
se métamorphoser en tout près de 300
personnes y sont logés et pendant les
compétitions des centaines de bénévoles
et jusqu'à 50000 spectateurs se
compteront sur le site c'est un
organisation monumental quand on n'est
pas dedans on peut pas imaginer le
boulot qui pourrait avoir pour comeau on
a prévu un planning en amont on a
commencé à installer le 1er août donc on
a réussi à monter ça dans un temps
record
tout bien tout est prêt pour accueillir
dès demain une des preuves les plus
importantes de ces jeux le concours
complet
anthony mastodonte jaunes reçus mais
pour nous la compétition ces jeux
équestres premier podium des jeux se
sont déroulés hier avec henning le sacre
attendu des américains avec un qui
décidément et roanne sont indétrônables
après jerez en 2002 après aix la
chapelle en 2006 après lexington en 2010
ils ont décroché hier leur quatrième
titre de champion du monde par équipes
ils étaient les grands favoris ils n'ont
pas failli ils ont même offert du grand
spectacle sur la deuxième marche du
podium on retrouve la belgique la
médaille de bronze elle revient à
l'autriche quant à la france c'est bien
elle ne termine que 10e et ce malgré
quelques très belles prestations et
notamment celle d'anne sophie guirand un
peu déçu mais je pensais qu'il vise est
une 6e place trois cavaliers français
participeront quand même à la consolante
de la finale en individuel avant de
parler par adressage on part tout au
stade d'ornano se poursuit en ce moment
même la compétition de dressage avec le
grand prix spécial
où vous vous trouvez autre dandenault
corinne de rosa bonjour on attendait ce
matin de cavaliers français oui et je
suis avec hard auxerre qui vient de
passer à l'instant arnaud il ya eu de
très très belles choses que votre cheval
lusitanien et puis quelques petits
soucis sur les changements de pied oui
oui le cheval la jeune tchèque 9 ans
l'objectif était de faire le grand prix
spécial donc il est passé mardi donc
d'hier donc n'a pas eu le temps de
retravailler le grand prix spécial donc
c'est un peu un péché de jeunesse du
cheval un peu de fatigue si donc âgé
quelques fautes sur les lignes mais bon
terrain technique n'attendiez pas vous
retrouver ici aujourd'hui
par l'objectif prioritaire à l'objectif
prioritaire c'est peut-être le mieux
possible pour l'équipe et ensuite on
espérait quand même faire partie du
spécial mais on savait que ce serait
difficile vous avez un parcours très
atypique vous avez commencé par le horse
ball ça vous avez monté par le dressage
vous êtes revenu horse ball vous avez
monté
voilà vous vous êtes monté l'ont
longtemps en seconde ça vous fait quoi
d'être ici en dressage c'est une fierté
après c'est mon travail et puis toujours
gérer des chevaux je faisais du horse
ball pour m'amuser donc c'est beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de patientes c'est
difficile donc je
prépare le choix depuis deux ans pour
cette échéance donc c'est assez bien
jamais contents merci merci
voilà et puis le para dressage se
poursuit également anthony après deux
jours de compétition les épreuves de
parra dressage ce foutu et effectivement
ce matin alors c'est un peu plus
difficile de s'y retrouver en para
dressage est liée à plusieurs niveaux de
compétition suivant les handicaps ça
fonctionne par une balade en grade 3 une
reprise un peu moins bonne que celle du
premier tour pour samuel katell sur
mogador de volant chez matin sur ces
images on suivra de près le classement
de la france qui pour l'instant est tout
à fait honorable et roanne merci anthony
demain la grande épreuve dès 7 heures du
matin ce sera l'endurance à un marathon
de 160 km dans la baie du mont saint
michel et l'on s'arrête ce midi sur
cette discipline de l'endurance une
épreuve dans laquelle il faut saluer
vite les aussi surveiller le coeur de
son cheval présentation avec ses
reportages signés donc anthony masto et
patrick soulabaille
20 40 90 et jusqu'à 160km de nombreuses
épreuves d'endurance sont organisées
partout dans francs chaque week-end et
notamment dans le web ce jour là nous
avons rendez-vous à tonquédec au coeur
de la bretagne
nous y retrouvons valérie et son cheval
ou deux paires david important arabe de
nouveau ils vont partir pour 40 km en
fait il faut qu'on se qualifie pour
atteindre des courses de 90 ou 120 donc
là les courses de 20 40 60 c'est
tranquille qu'en fait comme on le vit
comme ça par contre après oui quand on
atteint des courses de 90 km vitesse
libre ou là si le premier qui arrive
qu'à gagner balas et c'est la
compétition
et tandis que valérie prend le départ
chaque son compagnon lui en la route il
doit retrouver valérie tous les 5 km en
moyenne et ce n'est pas si simple
l'endurance équestre est un travail d
qui dans sa camionnette jacques fait
suivre la logistique à chaque point de
rencontre il faut refroidir le cheval et
éventuellement le faire boire car la
cadence et soutenu il y à un rythme à
respecter d'ailleurs jacques
s'inquiètent de ne pas voir arriver
valérie
il faut 40 minimum 2 km heure au maximum
15 km heure pour être classé les gens
que sur ces courses là beaucoup de gens
viennent pour assurer la qualification
est donc prennent pas de risque je pense
pas qu'aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que
ça va pas payer du tout quoi
il fait frais ouzoud est en forme
valérie prend à peine le temps de
s'arrêter
comme les autres concurrents elle doit
maintenant terminée rapidement sa
première boucle
valérie yeosu d' à mal finalement ses 20
premiers kilomètres en un peu moins
d'une heure et
il n'a pas plu mais c'est assez unique
donc pas tous à la tension donc j'allais
un peu de route pour début et après
quand j'ai pu galoper à mâcher j'essaie
de récupérer mon retard que j'avance est
vraiment pas vite soit
valérie doit maintenant attendre une
heure avant de repartir dès que le
rythme cardiaque de tours cheval sera
redescendue élira le présenter au
vétérinaire comme le veut le règlement
d'être sûr que le cheval peut repartir
sur la prochaine et donc la fréquence
cardiaque le soin normale inférieure à
64 que le transit également ce normal et
surtout que le cheval soit pop boiteux
un bon cheval d'endurance et cheval dont
le plan ne va pas trop vite c'est l'une
des qualités des pur sang arabe une race
que l'on trouve dans quelques élevages
bretons est réputé de grandes fortunes
des émirats passionnés d'endurance bien
qu'ils cherchent leurs chevaux
l équipe n évolue d'abord les thèmes
mondialisé avec eux db son acheteur de
chevaux c'est vrai que ça fait
développer l'élevage et ça fait aussi
une recherche de dans la génétique et
d'un la morphologie de chou est d'aller
plus loin plus le
retour dans la course à peine le temps
de regarder le décor médiéval
valérie doit maintenir le rythme
l'épreuve se terminera finalement sans
encombre notre cavalière et son cheval
décrochent leur qualification pour les
épreuves de niveau supérieur
antonio on compare souvent cette épreuve
à un marathon de course à pied en fait
attend à ceci près qu'il y à quatre
phases de récupération pendant cette
course une course qui fait quand même
160 km 1 demain pas de 9h à cheval dans
un cadre magnifique qu'est la baie du
mont saint michel deux cent soixante
cavaliers sont engagés dont 5 français
et notamment un voisin breton denis le
guillou il faut dire que la bretagne est
la région qui compte le plus grand
nombre de licenciés en endurance et
l'histoire de 2000 guillou est assez
intéressante car il est amateur dans la
vraie vie est en fait dirigeant d'une
pme ils concourent sur au titre j'espère
que j'ai corrige pas le nom de son
cheval un petit anglo-arabe de 12 ans et
on suivra de près tous les cavaliers
français car il ya peut-être là des
espoirs de médaille même si en
individuel ce sont les émirats arabes le
qatar et l'espagne qui m'ont jouer le
tout pour le tout ils seront également
surveillées de près car on sait que dans
cette discipline l'endurance il ya eu
quelques dérapages et notamment en ce
qui concerne le dopage on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir et roanne et on
l'a dit autour de sartilly les cavaliers
se mesureront dans le cadre majestueux
de la baie du mont saint michel à un
très beau spectacle en perspective
plus de 5000 spectateurs sont attendus
tous les billets ont été vendus
multiples reste encore une possibilité
d'assister à la compétition nomme son
billet infos pratiques avec stéphanie
vino et joël a marre
l'endurance c'est un circuit de 160
kilomètres répartis en cinq parcours
pour les gens qui ont acheté un billet
il est conseillé d'arriver sur le site
de sortie dès 6 heures du matin pour
assister au départ vers 7 heures sans
billets il suffit de se positionner sur
le bord de la route cet endroit avec des
parkings ont été tout spécialement
préparé pour accueillir le public en a
imaginé un dispositif pour les
spectateurs qui peuvent se rendre sur
les plages de jullouville de karongue
carole de dragey afin d'aller voir la
course à des forces bien précises
puisque les heures de passage on
communique les îles pour avoir les
détails des boucles et des horaires de
passage il suffit de se rendre sur le
site internet des jeux équestres
mondiaux en voiture le circuit est libre
d'accès la seule contrainte de
circulation ce jour là sera la kz2
grange qui sera coupé de 7h à 10h au
niveau de saint pierre langers la
première boucle emprunté par un
concurrent cession' le rd 973 au niveau
de la commune de saint pierre langers
donc là on est obligé
d'interrompre totalement la circulation
dans les deux sens pendant le passage
des chevaux qui s'effectue en deux
phases une phase again phase retour il
est donc conseillé aux automobilistes
qui ferait avranches granville ou
inversement de passer par la haye-pesnel
pour éviter le secteur
en direct est toujours des jeux
équestres montebourg continue de jongler
entre les disciplines et on retourne au
stade d'ornano se poursuivre elle des
preuves et là le grand prix spécial
individuel de dressage corinne bureau
serait il y avait deux français ce matin
on a entendu tout à l'heure arnaud serre
il y avait également marc boblet oui
marc blais qui n'était pas prévu dans
cette finale aujourd'hui et qui a été
repêché in extremis hier soir donc il a
fait une bonne prestation ce matin avec
sa très belle jument noble dream il est
pour l'instant dans les dix premiers du
classement provisoire mais les meilleurs
sont à passer donc il faudra attendre la
fin de la journée pour voir si marc
boblet fera partie des 15 meilleurs ceux
qui auront droit à disputer la reprise
libre en musique mercy corps et non on
va maintenant faire un tour dans les
allées du village des jeux dans lequel
nous sommes installés toute cette
semaine on va retrouver au raid misery
bonjour aurélie vous allez nous faire
des copains sports équestres très peu
connu mais bonjour air marne il s'agit
du polo crosse alors un sport
affectivement méconnu et pourtant
l'équipe de france un joli palmarès
d'avoir remporté la coupe du monde en
2011 et le challenge européen en 2010
pour nous expliquer les règles de ce
sport australien qui se pratique
essentiellement dans les pays du
commonwealth je vais rejoint barbara
beaufils coach de l'équipe de france
hier barbara se trouve dans une partie
de l'équipe de france bonjour barbara
d'abord il faut pas confondre le polo et
le poulpe est tout à fait en fait le
boulot cross à être créé dans les années
1930 en australie pour démocratiser le
polo c'est un peu le sport des fermiers
australienne et ça se joue avec une
baraque est donc complètement différente
une d'un maillet de polo et une balle en
caoutchouc avec mon pass aérienne est la
particularité c'est qu'on a un cavalier
un cheval sur un terrain qui fait à peu
près la tête un terrain de foot 1 alors
qu'un terrain de polo fait quatre
terrains de foot avec une grosse
cavalerie dans chaque équipe trois
cavaliers mais un seul marc oui alors la
particularité c'est que chacun un rôle
sur le terrain le numéro un c'est le
buteur le numéro 2 c'est le joueur
central et les numéros 3 c'est le
défenseur c'est un sport qui fait aussi
la part belle à la parité 1 puisque
l'équipe de france est et mixte vous
vous êtes là pour promouvoir ce sport
qui n'est pas une discipline des jeux
équestres mondiaux propre et de
licencier leur enfonce il ya très peu de
licenciés ont démarré en 2007 on a
commencé en 2007 on a à peu près 320
douzaine de clubs cependant en australie
on a plus de 8000 joueurs qu'on c'est un
sport qui est quand même populaire dans
une bonne partie du monde et on espère
qu'il va se développer démonstration
cette fois de polo je vous le rappelle
sam 10 septembre c'est à deauville un
merci aurélie c'est jeu au pied
l'occasion de s'intéresser à la filière
cheval de nombreux métiers pente autour
de l'équitation notamment en normandie à
mieux dans le domaine de la santé une
spécialité arts à celle de ostéopathe
équin découverte avec ce reportage
d'emilie flahaut et francs
cette affiche est un indice pour les
passions de geoffroy blanchot s'ils
consultent rarement l'après midi c'est
parce qu'il se consacre à d'autres
passions beaucoup plus imposant mais
beaucoup moins bavard
ok tu fais demi tour
où commençait toujours sage comme ça
toujours toujours toujours pour voir
comment le cheval second d'olive justo
pas voir comment ils engagent voir
comment il utilise sa ligne de dos si on
a des styles très ou des asymétries au
niveau des postérieurs de la coupe deux
épaules dans son ensemble avoir une
vision d'ensemble de la mécanique une
mécanique qui n'est d'ailleurs pas très
éloigné celle des hommes mais comme il
leur manque la parole l'ostéopathie
qu'un utilisent les réflexes musculaire
naturel du cheval pour comprendre d'où
viennent ces douleurs ça c'est un
réflexe de jumeaux naturel chez certains
shows de même que celui ci est en fait
c'est ce qui nous permet à nous de
pouvoir tester leurs artistes n'ont
pratiquement dans son ensemble rachètent
leurs sales blancs beurs sans avoir à
forcer or c'est comme un âne et après
c'est l'éducation de la main qui va
venir si le cheval ou plus ou moins
douloureux et surtout si on un blocage
comme ici sur une charnière dorso
lombaire et il y en ait du travail sur
pelote qui se laisse faire sans broncher
car elle sent que geoffroy blanchot lui
fait du bien
on ne demande pas plus que ce qu'il ne
pourrait pas faire
juste de venir elle va venir tout seul
est là où sa fille j'ai un petit peu
payé une perte de mobilité articulaire
je vais venir chercher un axe je
manipulais pour libérer l'articulation
pour être cités au pathé qu'un il faut
seulement monter râches pas pour
connaître une sensation il faut accepter
aussi que la profession ne soit pas
encore reconnu le cadre vega d'exercice
est encore floue alors mieux vaut avoir
la double casquette
qu'est ce qui est plus d'un les humains
les cheveux je fonctionne beaucoup plus
facilement gérable a sonné monsieur
parce qu'une personne anxieuse on était
scellé un cheval anxieux ou du monde
qu'on n'est pas dangereux pour lui il va
et c'est ce que je lis pelote qui est
prête pour une petite sieste
nelson monfort bonjour les
téléspectateurs de france 3 auront le
plaisir de vous retrouver pour une heure
de direct cet après midi aux alentours
de 15 heures c'est exact sur france 3
national depuis avant-hier nous nous
sommes présents en compagnie de
christian georges et des coûts pris
puisque cet après midi
en direct à la phase ultime durant la
phase ultime du dressage qui me remplit
qualification pour les 15 meilleurs en
musique ce sera pour ce week end nous
sommes très heureux d'être ici d'être
jaloux d'être ici en votre compagnie
merci d'être sur ce plateau également le
12 13 et s'achèvent ce qui concerne la
partie régionale il se poursuit avec la
météo puis votre édition nationale ce
soir vous retrouvez en basse-normandie
et un 19/20 présenté en direct de ces
jeux équestres à internet les jeux
équestres continue également sur le web
et que notre site internet bastille ray
normandie poids france 3 points et faire
très bonne journée à tous et à demain